Bueno yo en esto quise hacer mucho menos
voluntarioso y un poco más de frío en mi
cálculo y aplicar esto de la Real
política yo estoy muy concuerdo con lo
que se dijo recientemente no de nuevo la
pregunta de hoy era única y
exclusivamente usted aceptó rechaza la
propuesta constitucional y por lo que
hemos hasta ahora esta respuesta esta
propuesta ha sido rechazada por tanto no
Y bueno ya está Perdón sacada de
actualizar el 48%, no con la brecha
Sacada actualizar 48% con un 37 de 62
Disculpe esto de está pasando en este
segundo con este respaldo
con este respaldo con el que tiene el
rechazo efectivamente
la tradicional de ese derecho y centro
derecha va a quedar sumamente empoderada
no tiene ningún incentivo a cambiar nada
de lo que de la constitución del 80 que
es la que en cierto sentido es aceptada
y plebiscitada
interpretación política del hecho y por
tanto yo creo que de la misma forma que
ha sido tan difícil de o a resistido
tantos cambios los últimos 30 años hoy
día con este respaldo político de la
ciudadanía va a seguir aguantando unos
años más por qué Porque la elección era
solamente aprueba o rechaza nada más que
eso Por más que las campañas políticas
era esta no otra así rechazo para
mejorar rechazo para cambiar nada de eso
fue solamente un eslogan de campaña fue
voluntarioso y nada de eso hoy día o
mañana Por así decirlo es es un cheque
que se puede ir a cobrar esta brecha que
da el electorado da un espaldarazo o
Perdón da un empuje político sumamente
importante al rechazo a los sectores por
lo general mucho más conservadores de la
ciudadanía y que finalmente
cruzan mucho más allá si dividimos al
electorado lo que se vive
tradicionalmente la política Chile entre
izquierda centro derecha aquí
efectivamente podemos ver que la
izquierda en términos tradicionales de
nuevo es una etiqueta que resume mucho
por lo tanto no lo explica todo
queda marginalizada o muy muy escaso
poder y mucho el perdón de muy poco
Rango de acción por tanto mañana
distintos personajes políticos en las
cuales la campaña del rechazo muy
exitosamente logró esconder en el último
mes el último dos meses yo creo que van
a reaparecer con bastante contentos con
toda esta fuerza y van a promover
perpetuar la constitución del 80 no o
simplemente evitar las más menores
cambios que se pueden hacer